I put on a pretty dress
for you, Jimmy.
-You look gorgeous.
-What's up, fellas?
-Come on. It's so good to --
-So nice to be here.
Hi, everybody.
-Dude. I know, right?
Doesn't it feel good
to have the audience?
-I know. It's so weird.
-It's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And wonderful. Wonderful.
-Thank you for doing the show.
We did the show, obviously,
from Zoom
when everyone was at home,
and I appreciate you doing that.
But to see you in person,
I want to say congrats
on so many things.
-Thank you.
-"The Equalizer."
I mean, it's a giant hit.
It's a smash. You're fantastic.
-Thank you, thank you,
thank you!
-I want to get into that,
but first, you were honored
with a BET Lifetime
Achievement Award,
and I want to say congrats
on that.
-Thank you so much.
-Here's a picture of you.
-Ah. Pops.
-There's you and Pops
right there.
-Me and Pops.
-I love your dad so much.
-Hey, Dad!
-I just -- I just saw it, and,
honestly, I was like, "Whew."
'Cause if I didn't know if I --
I didn't want to get
too emotional,
but that's a big deal.
-I mean, yeah,
it kind of came out of nowhere,
and it was --
I was like, "For real?"
-'Cause I mean, that's --
-I'm kind of young for
a lifetime achievement award.
-Yeah, exactly. You have
so much more life to give.
Exactly. But, I mean, that's --
-Yeah, it was cool.
-It's a good list of --
of people you're on.
I mean, Prince --
I mean, you're on there
with a lot of awesome people.
-I know. That's what I said.
I looked up the list,
and I'm like,
"Wow. This is crazy," you know?
-That was wild, but you
deserve it. It's awesome.
I like that you went on
with Pops,
but I also love
that you brought a --
a photo of your mom.
-That's right.
I had to bring my mom with me.
Love you, Mommy.
Yeah.
-She'd be so proud. Come on.
-Yo, thank you, again.
You know, our moms
look out for us, Jimmy.
You got to always know that.
-Yup.
-Jimmy sent me shepherd's pie.
You sent me shepherd's pie.
You know, I lost my mom, and --
and all of a sudden,
this delivery comes to the door.
And I'm like, "What is that?"
You know?
-Yeah, yeah. What are you --
-What is --
And it was food from Jimmy.
Jimmy sent me a bunch
of shepherd's pie.
And I'm like, "That's so weird."
-I didn't know what to do.
-Man, we smashed
that shepherd's pie!
-Right.
You know what I'm saying?
-I didn't know that
we would need so much food!
We tore that shepherd's pie up.
So thank you, again.
Everybody needed that,
and you are the best.
-I love you. I love you.
I heard that you just did
a movie with Adam Sandler.
Is that true?
-Yes. I love -- Man.
-How was --
How was Adam Sandler?
He's the greatest.
-Adam Sandler is so --
-You guys together?
I'm going to freak out.
-We were in Philly, too.
I mean, it was crazy. Yes.
We -- We did a movie
called "Hustle."
I cannot wait for you all
to see it.
My dream came true.
I play Adam's wife.
-Yes!
That's what I'm talking about.
-Yes. I've had a quest.
-Those are the best things.
-He is the best,
and it was just so much fun
working with him
and just, like --
You know, he's carrying around
a bucket of music, you know?
It's just like this bucket box
of sound and --
-And he's just walking
around having --
-He's a sweetheart.
Just having fun
and making everybody happy.
-Which is the key, right?
-Yeah.
-That's the key to anything.
-And it's so different
from what I do
on "The Equalizer."
I'm, like, going hard all day.
Like -- [ Grunting ]
You know?
-And then I get to like, "Ah."
-Yeah, but you --
-Adam Sandler.
-You get to -- By the way --
-A movie set.
-You're crushing
on "The Equalizer."
I love it.
Do you like doing it?
I mean, all this crazy --
-I do.
-I mean, you're good at it.
-Well, finally,
those, uh, gunslinging skills
I've been working on
all my life...
-Yeah, it paid off. Exactly.
-...karate.
-Yes.
-But let's talk --
It premiered
after the Super Bowl.
The biggest ratings in, like,
10 years or something crazy.
Number-one show
for the whole year.
-Yeah. Thank you, thank you.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
For making it number one.
-And it's fantastic.
-You can do it again.
-And great reviews.
-Yeah.
-You said the show
was a role of a lifetime.
What can fans expect
for season two?
-They can expect the same
action, emotion, tension.
Fun. A fun ride.
Just a good fun ride
for an hour.
-It really is.
-And some justice, you know?
And that's the best part
about be--
you know, playing this character
in "The Equalizer."
I get to, like, mete justice,
make sure that the good people
get what they deserve, you know,
and -- and people
who can't help themselves get --
get a good shake, so --
-You get to do everything.
-And I get to do it,
while, you know, gunslingin'.
And cracking backs!
-Cracking backs. Come on.
It is great, though.
And I watch it,
and I go, "Oh, my gosh."
It's just perfect.
I'm so happy for you.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Queen Latifah in season
two of "The Equalizer."
Take a look.
-Oh, we got a few texts on
the board that deserve a look.
Word on the alt net is
that you are a real-life hero.
Your legend is growing.
-Yeah, that's a problem.
I'm too exposed.
When I was working overseas,
no one knew who I was.
Now my legend has grown
all the way to the DA's office.
Cops know about me.
Delilah does, too?
Maybe I was foolish thinking
I could do this work
so close to home.
I don't know, guys.
Maybe it's time we stop.
♪♪
-Yeah.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
Queen Latifah, everybody.
Season two of "The Equalizer"
premieres this Sunday.
-Whoo!
-This Sunday.
Set your DVR. Set your TiVos.